where can you find a video that includes
the rise of the world's most dynamic
sport powerful corrupt unions their
politician cronies and this stay tuned
to find out
[Music]
mixed martial arts it's one of the
fastest growing sports in the world
today with its athletes now being some
of the most popular in the world this is
a sport that has now practiced across
nearly every state in this great country
one notable exception however is the
state of New York
leftists have been late to hop on the
freedom bandwagon this state and instead
insist on banning it but before we get
to that for those who don't know let me
give you a brief introduction on the
history of how this great sport came to
be but my father realized that in order
to showcase the effectiveness of gracie
jiu-jitsu to the world it had to be put
on television so that's what inspired
him to create the Ultimate Fighting
Championship he chose his younger
brother hoist to represent our families
fighting system boys went in there
daveed those giants winning three out of
the first four ufc's and the rest was
history yes folks as a matter of fact
before it was sanctioned and came to be
the sport that it is today the activity
wasn't all too safe and people did have
reason to be concerned when I first
started fighting there were no weight
divisions no time limit Holies no gloves
anything goes the only rules were no
biting and going
gouging you can grab their hair you can
if they're growing they punch the back
of the head elbow in the back of the
head things like that that gold doesn't
stop fighting again beneath that money
and then on the last one I gonna let go
you know I do a good service over but
before you go and say that Luther
politicians had reason to ban it
understand that things have changed now
there are you know rounds weight
divisions no striking to the spine no
stretching to the back of the head no
kicking the downed opponent no meaning
the downed opponent you know a lot of
different things have been put in place
for the safety of the athletes we are
the sport evolved to these of the sport
and I can see even as an Olympic sport
in the official you know it's it's how
you have amazing athletes now and you
have the rounds you have to wake the
visions if she became a sport it can
bathe itself back to the 2001 Nevada
State Legislature where they're
attempting to get a law passed when you
do that you must identify what it is
you're encompassing so they care what
the term mixed martial arts MMA and
that's very important to know it's very
important because at times you'll hear
people and generally if not always in a
negative fashion to speak of MMA well
these two kids were out on the
playground doing MMA and somebody got
hurt I'm gonna wait just a second we
don't do MMA on playgrounds that the MMA
is a legal term if it's not done legally
if it's not regulated if it's not in a
state that welcomes it regulates it
oversees it it's not MMA it's something
else it's something that may resemble it
or look like it in your opinion but if
there was no way in there was no
sanctioning if there was no government
regulatory body it's not Mme Mme is a
legal term because of these unified
rules the sport became much safer wildly
popular not to mention the huge amounts
of revenue generated to local economies
hosting these live sporting events and
it's for that reason that most major
sanctioning athletic bodies across the
country came to be very enthusiastically
on board with the sport of MMA Nevada
California New Jersey Ohio the list goes
on and on one notable exception however
would be the state of New York as a
matter of fact politicians in new
have been some of the most vocal
opponents condemning the sport the
greatest problem I find with mixed
martial arts or Ultimate Fighting is
that it's violent the opponent in boxing
cannot slam them in the head there's a
purpose for that and the reason is
safety well when you combine the two
that's when you have the problem
actually mixed martial arts is safer
than boxing well let me get this are mr.
what you're telling me that it's safer
to be a boxer than to go into Ultimate
Fighting where you're in a little cage
and you can kick somebody use your elbow
your knee you can just beat the living
daylights out of them anyway in shape or
form come on who's gonna lose there's
never been a death or serious injury in
the 12-year history of the Ultimate
Fighting Championship if my son thought
he was gonna be a professional boxer
I'll be very worried the reality's the
Train he's getting hit every day every
day so that for sure is gonna have a
long lasting damaging on your brain and
we have different options we have
finishing holes who have takedowns C
mixed martial arts of fightin and a
variety of ways notably submissions I
can knee bar I can choke hold I can toe
hold she taps out and we both walk away
with our health and tax not so in boxing
even if you look at the actual knockouts
in the sport of mixed martial arts the
fighters out the rep steps in and calls
it to preserve his safety not so in
boxing a guy can get beaten into
oblivion unconscious on the ground the
ref gives him a standing eight-count he
stands back up to continue to absorb
more blunt force trauma to the brain see
what's dangerous in a fight is limiting
one's natural defense options you can
clinch you can
you can wrestle in boxing the referee
separates you and says no no no no no no
keep pounding each other in the face
causing more boy trauma to the brain
repeatedly and we all know how that ends
up for boxers long-term I won't wait NIT
you're saying I'm doing Simba I mean Kim
boy is gonna get much ladies they won't
get to the end let's call him up I'm
gonna walk with Jane soon and that time
to do this see fine so we've established
that it's not really a safety issue but
don't take my word for it I believe that
violence begets violence now in New York
State the legislature and the governor
constantly are trying to do away with
violence violence in schools violence in
our urban cities oh so the state of New
York doesn't host any boxing football or
hockey events of course that's not the
case see the banning of the sport of
mixed martial arts
in 2012 makes no sense to any
freedom-loving American that is until
you start doing a little more digging
and do a little research basically it
comes down to the fact that in Nevada in
the state of Nevada
the 42 brothers who owned a majority of
the UFC they also run the palace tissue
casinos are the station casinos over in
in Nevada and they have been battling
with the culinary Union over in Nevada
for a very long time because the
culinary union wants their hotels to be
and casinos to be unionized New York
being a very strong union state they
have influence here their parent company
is this group unite here which are the
ones who are lobbying against MMA and
they're the ones who are stopping it so
basically you know that they did very
well in the Senate they made it they
pass on the votes and then they don't
even make it to the point where Sheldon
Silver is even going to open this to a
vote the bigger thing at play is the
politicians that are keeping it out are
being dishonest with their people you
can't do that as a politician if you
want to come forward and say listen
we're having some conflicting things
here I'm a union guy I got into office
off the union's the unions have a
problem
the days all the way across the country
with some members of Zuffa which which
only you'll see if they want to come out
and say that fine it really has nothing
to do with the sport it has to do with
their issue with the UFC and their issue
with the UFC is really their issue with
the Fertitta brothers and their issue
with the 14o brothers really stems to
this this issue in nevada where they're
not unionizing they're their casinos
okay so the very large very powerful
culinary Union seem to be wanting to
strong-arm members of the UFC based on a
personal business decision issue but
could that have anything to do with Bob
Riley and mr. silver in New York so
vocally and baselessly condemning the
sport well as I've shown in my channel
many times when you want to think of the
corrupt relationship between lobbyists
and government Big Oil big pharma while
they sound sexy in the media are nowhere
near as powerful as big unions and one
thing about unions is they really
understand the process they truly are
ingrained and they understand the
political process and they often get
their way through that sometimes it's by
bowling sometimes it's by buying but
they work within the rules they
understand the process but you need to
be honest about it and if you think the
culinary union is the only one that
understands the process you're wrong
they are small so if a politician in New
York is willing to lie to protect them
imagine what he's gonna do for the drug
companies imagine what he's gonna do for
the big conglomerates okay so at the end
of the day who does this really hurt
well for one certainly the athletes
making a living in this sport well for
me it was you know everybody comes from
a different background but for me I was
in college
had planned on wrestling in college and
originally actually planned on playing
football in college but my mom got sick
with heart problems so I have to leave
school go home take care of her was
working three jobs pouring concrete
during the day and then bartending at
night at a couple different clubs just
was not able to keep up I'm very
fortunate in that I'm doing what I want
to do I'm not forced to this position I
haven't been drafted I'm a I'm a
volunteer in the army I'm here because I
want to be here
the downside is my goodness is so hard
the the day-to-day is so hard it started
like you've always got to be a way to
make chunks of money so I started
fighting professional kickboxing and
boxing matches so tough man contest and
everything I could
your CJ now
I saw that that was my sport you know
that was my way of winning the world
title making some money to help my mom
out things like that I get up when it's
dark I got a bed when it's dark every
day it doesn't matter if it's a holiday
weekend you accomplish your daily chores
and just a matter of taking care of the
animals in the property in with training
and your training to to absolute
exhaustion twice a day I think it made
me made me grow up you know because when
you don't have be for a trader
then you got a sec mom
either be telling me oh no you
completely check out you know so it
obviously changed my life this is
something I chose to do someday it will
be gone I won't be doing any more I
don't miss it when that day comes but
more importantly the citizens of New
York as the UFC and MMA have proven to
generate huge revenues in any city they
visit reports have increased local
revenue as high as 40 million dollars in
Toronto after a single event was held 40
million dollars
imagine what New Yorkers could do with
all that money that's a lot of subway
rides and bagel farts let's be fair we
don't need New York but New York sure
could use us we don't have to do
business in New York we can be plenty
successful we are and we're not in New
York New York is struggling and we can
show that we can bring ten million
dollars to an economy in a five day
period we can show those numbers I would
say it certainly hurts the people who
owned businesses in New York because
there's gonna be a fun influx a massive
amount of fans are gonna be at the show
hotels food servers this is a revenue to
be generated to the state of New York
you know it should it be generate for
the state here and it's not being
because the stupid politicians are
holding back so folks nobody is forced
into the Octagon and this is far from a
bloodsport
this is a serious mainstream sport
consisting of athletes all of whom are
sons brothers fathers and fellow
Americans and don't let corrupt
politicians financially indebted to even
more corrupt unions for their political
safety try and tell you otherwise
so whether you're a fan of a school
or not if you're a fan of freedom if
you're a fan of a government for the
people by the people and you want to
make a difference forward this video
along and contact your local
representative it's time to keep these
Schmoe hawks accountable the problem is
when a politician comes out and he lies
if a guy is willing to lie about a sport
that doesn't matter what's he willing to
do on state health care what's he
willing to do on state welfare
what's he willing to do on state
education of the kids
what's he willing to do on police
services and emergency services for
seniors if he's willing to lie to keep
us sport out who else combined
[Music]